Sandra the southern border may not be
the only source of the migrant crisis
that's plaguing the Biden Administration
officials are now warning that America's
northern border with Canada is being
flooded with illegal Crossings with more
migrants apprehended there in the past
11 months than the past 10 years
combined let's bring in New Hampshire
Republican gubernatorial candidate and
former senator from the granite state
Kelly ayotte Senator it's good to talk
to you uh last week last week there was
a Mexican national who was in the U.S
illegally who was arrested for smuggling
in people to New Hampshire what came
through Vermont from Canada again this
person should not have been in the
country yet this person also had a
Washington state driver's license that
was presented to the police you argue as
a gubernatorial candidate that not
enough attention is being paid to our
northern border make the case well there
there's not enough attention being paid
there the Biden administration's open
border policies are causing a surge over
the northern border you just talked
about the statistics over the last 11
months they've had thousands of illegal
immigrants that have been arrested from
76 different countries John over our
northern border more than in the last 10
years and recently we had indicted on
New Hampshire's northern border what
you've talked about a Mexican immigrant
who was trafficking people illegally
into New Hampshire and also before that
I visited up Pittsburgh New Hampshire a
farm up there a very beautiful idyllic
Farm where the the farmers actually
intercepted drugs on their property and
are worried about illegal immigrants
that are coming on their property and
they should be able to live in peace so
this is what you get with the open
border policies so that's why our
governor sununu has called for more
resources but he's being ignored by the
Biden Administration and so I'm also
calling for more resources law law
enforcement out there wants the help and
they need the help you know they do when
you take a look at the the statistics in
that Swanton sector as it's known which
is encompasses part of New York State
Vermont and New Hampshire I want to take
it the look at the statistics all the
way across the border from the
Washington State all the way to Maine
2023 so far 150 743 people have been
intercepted compare that to 109 000 last
year and just 27 000 in 2021 you
mentioned that you toured the Border I
want to put up a picture of something
that you tweeted out here where you went
on the property uh with those folks
who've been dealing with this we we hear
about ranchers in Texas dealing with
people who are smuggling drugs across
the border you don't really associate
that with our our neighbor to the north
I mean I grew up in Canada and
cross-border smuggling was never a big
thing when I was a kid
well unfortunately it is now because the
law is not being enforced and you know
the farm where you showed the picture of
me uh standing with the ATV wonderful
people of their family has had that farm
uh for many decades and they've never
had to worry about this before but now
they're worried for their children
they're worried uh that they've already
intercepted drugs on their property and
illegal immigrants coming over and they
shouldn't have to worry about that and
that's why there needs to be additional
resources for law enforcement at the
border and we need to enforce our laws
so this impact is impacting New
Hampshire from the south because the
drugs are being trafficked in and now
drugs are being trapped again from the
north too it's a very untenable
situation speaking of enforcing the law
uh there is a provision in the New
Hampshire Constitution that you have to
have the first in the nation
presidential primary Republicans are
going to do it next year Democrats say
no we're changing and we're going to do
South Carolina First well New Hampshire
Democrats say that they are going to
defy the DNC and they're going to go
ahead and be first in the nation RFK Jr
supports this he said quote I thoroughly
support New Hampshire's century-old
status as the first primary State and
the political culture that has grown up
around it everyone knows the real reason
the DNC made the change the people of
South Carolina didn't ask for it no it's
simply another undemocratic attempt to
rig the primary process in favor of
their anointed candidate Joe Biden we
talked to Governor Chris sununu when
this was first proposed he was incensed
by it this is a bipartisan issue because
folks in the granite state take their
first in the nation status very
seriously whether you're Republican or
Democrat
John you're right we do and we play such
an important role of vetting these
candidates and what I think
unfortunately is happening is that uh
Joe Biden doesn't want to campaign in
New Hampshire because he's afraid to
actually answer those hard questions
that New Hampshire voters ask whether
it's in the diners at the town halls and
you know he wants the system to be
rigged for him in this primary and the
way I look at it is that yes this is a
bipartisan issue because it's important
that if you're running for president
that you actually have to talk to voters
answer the tough questions that you
shouldn't pick the states that you're
going to appear in and so I know
Governor sununa is fighting very hard on
this issue we all agree and I'm so glad
by the way to see all the Republican
presidential candidates who are in New
Hampshire they are here every day
they're working hard uh they're shaking
the hands they're answering the tough
questions they're doing the town halls
and and showing that our party is one uh
that is going to reach out to voters
that understands the import words of the
New Hampshire primary to making sure
that we have a presidential candidate
that can appeal to the entire country
well memory serves then candidate Joe
Biden did not fare very well in the New
Hampshire primary back in 2016. so it's
probably the reason for the change uh
Senator good to catch up with you thanks
so much we should mention too hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else